we will be going right back to these
hearings but before that i do want to go
to my friend and colleague bret baier uh
a special report best-selling author
brett the one thing that struck me uh
just talking leon panetta is thanks for
returning to afghanistan that eventually
will have to return what did you make of
that
well he's a guy that knows a lot former
cia director former defense secretary
someone who works with republicans and
democrats
and who knows the world and the world
and the reality is that terrorism is
going to be a problem
in some place that is a witch's brew of
radical islamic terrorists and that is
the taliban controlled afghanistan a
couple of things neil to note about
secretary blinken's testimony and the
questioning here
towards the end
when you had questions about how many
americans are on the ground the number
keeps coming back to roughly a hundred
well it's been roughly a hundred for a
couple of weeks from the administration
even after those two flights from
doha went to went to qatar uh from kabul
now it's still at roughly a hundred so
that number seems to be unsatisfying for
republicans especially on that committee
two was several thousand green card
holders how many is several thousand is
it two is it three is it five and did we
try to get them out or not and that is a
real question when asked about sivs the
special immigrant visa holders there is
no number they're trying to get a handle
the secretary said well that we're told
that that number is tens of thousands so
now you're looking at a situation where
the people who helped us for two decades
on the ground who are threatened by the
taliban
are really running for their lives still
and we can't get a firm number on what
that is or what we're doing to get them
out
do you think the secretary
is still safe in his job that he won't
be fired well i think in this point leon
panetta is exactly right that it's
president biden who if he determines
that blinken who is his long longtime
aide is safe
he's safe um i'm surprised that there
haven't been other resignations in other
parts of this chain
because this really was a horrible thing
from the intelligence that prevented
them from knowing the taliban was
gaining this to the actual
implementation you saw secretary blinken
say we inherited a deadline but we
didn't inherit a plan as far as
withdrawal
that doesn't cut it neil because they
inherited a deadline negotiated with
conditions-based negotiations as pointed
out by some of the republicans of may
first but then they renegotiated that
deal to make it september 11th
they renegotiated it but they didn't in
the interim come up with a plan about
how to get americans and other people
out by that date which is what led to
the situation that we saw
yeah i've always wondered how specious
and argument that was you just think
about it bret the white administration
came in
ripping up all sorts of deals and
actions taken by the prior
administration so why stop at this
particular one when it was indeed
adjusted to your point i guess what i'm
asking is we could put a forward sort of
spin on this now brett is this notion
that the taliban will continue
cooperating with us working with us to
get
these hundred or so americans out these
thousands of afghan nationals out um the
latter seems a little bit of a steep
climb here uh but in the interim the
vacuum is filled by the chinese
russians others uh
how do you see this playing out for the
administration
listen hope
is a plan i suppose but hope is not the
best thing for the people that are stuck
on the ground
and trusting the taliban that has a
pretty bad record neil is a
is uh thin
as far as
wanting to get real results
i i think there's an effort obviously
that continues every day and there's
also a private effort that continues
with former special ops officers and
we've heard a lot about that in recent
days
but
how this is going from a government
perspective
is not well and we are talking about the
taliban differently than we're talking
about uh pretty much anybody else
finally one point you mentioned earlier
about
it seems a bit incredulous to think that
you know the secretary of state wouldn't
know an exact number um but i'll take
him at its word that it's roughly 100
americans as you said that it's you know
a few thousand here could be a lot more
uh foreign nationals who work with us
uh
but wouldn't that be something a
secretary of state would know down to
the the exact
person and last person
they're arguing that it fluctuates uh
day to day people get out we find some
more people that are trying to get out
fine give them the benefit of the doubt
but the real number is in the thousands
of people that we should be getting out
if you talk to anybody in this business
including leon panetta who said we have
an obligation to those people on the
ground the one thing i thought secretary
panetta said that that i don't know if i
jive with by who the people i talk to
in the military circles and also
up on capitol hill is that would it have
been the exact same
under a trump administration this
how this went i i don't think that's
possible um because as bad as this went
there were conditions
baked into the taliban withdrawal and
i'm pretty sure just judging by the
people who are talking about it that
they wouldn't have left all these people
on the ground but we are where we are
and uh looking to the future you got to
get those people out
so that the taliban if it were to
actively
start taking over large swaths of the
country in this interim leading up to
the deadline they would not have
countenanced that
well there were
in the deal itself there were
loopholes that said if you do this the
thing's over and we get to decide when
we're leaving the deadline was not firm
if they didn't meet up with their
obligations they were not already
meeting up with those obligations and
now to say that the taliban suddenly is
going to be trusted even though the
document that they signed they never
lived up to but now they're going to be
trusted to get all these people out
again is a lot of hope but we'll see
we'll cover all sides
all right thank you very much bret
burger catching up with you hey sean
hannity here hey click here to subscribe
to fox news youtube page and catch our
hottest interviews and most compelling
analysis you will not get it anywhere
else